[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre quotidien dédié à
l'actualité locale voici les titres les
sujets que nous allons aborder au cours
de cette édition du 3 novembre journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
à l'école après le plan dévoilé hier par
le gouvernement ce sont les académies
qui aujourd'hui revenait sur le travail
des jeunes ambassadeurs le bouclier
sécurité neuf mois après la région fait
le point sur son action sous l'impulsion
de valérie pécresse les mesures d' aide
à la vidéoprotection d'un commune de
soutien à la police à la gendarmerie et
aux polices municipales municipales sont
elles efficaces
et puis dernier volet de notre dossier
consacré au surnaturel à l'occasion
d'halloween après l'étang des faits le
cavalier sans tête nous prendrons un peu
de hauteur avec des ovnis repérer dans
le ciel yvelinois 12% des écoles dans
les écoles primaires 10 % dans les
collèges et 4 % dans les lycées ces
chiffres représentent le nombre d'élèves
victimes de harcèlement scolaire dans
les établissements français depuis et
2012 l'éducation nationale met en place
des séminaires de sensibilisation
après les chefs d'établissements le
corps enseignant et les parents les
élèves eux mêmes ont été sensibilisés à
ce phénomène c'était le cas aujourd'hui
au lycée hôtelier de guyancourt près de
80 elle lycéens venus de tout le
département qui sont devenus donc de
jeunes ambassadeurs les explications de
mélanie poker
ces jeunes sont bien en train de mener
une enquête mais ne joue pas il cherche
à découvrir qui est harcelée ils sont
les ambassadeurs lycéens de lutte contre
le harcèlement
être ambassadeur ses manières de faire
avancer les choses je pense d'aider ceux
qui sont victimes de harcèlement de de
mieux connaître les gestes ou les
attitudes à avoir où on sera peut-être
plus amènes de voir certaines choses que
les profs les équipes éducatives ne
pourront pas voir je trouve que c'est
important que l'on sache un peu ce qui
se passe dans les collèges et lycées les
écoles et donc bassij si je peux en fait
contribué à cela et il l'expliqué à
d'autres camarades de mon lycée mais je
trouvais ça intéressant pour la deuxième
année la direction départementale de
l'éducation nationale forment ces
volontaires notamment à la question du
harcèlement à travers les réseaux
sociaux
un enfant sur dix aurait harcelé à
l'école avec le développement des outils
numériques et avec la banalisation de
l'usagé de ces outils
nos jeunes nos enfants sont de plus en
plus exposés et ce dès le plus jeune âge
puisque on appris aujourd'hui conscience
que l'école n'échappaient pas ce
phénomène c'est donc un phénomène
important qui peut avoir des
conséquences graves durable d'ailleurs
pour certains cas onze lycées de tout le
département participer à cette journée
de formation collégiens et primaires
devraient eux aussi être concernées
selon une enquête
hb assez le harcèlement au collège
aurait baissé de 15 % entre 2010 et 2014
à rien dans l'actualité également de ce
3 novembre la région ile de france qui
fait le bilan de son action de son plan
sécurité lancé en début d'année
celui ci prévoit notamment le
développement des équipements de
vidéosurveillance ou encore le
renforcement des moyens matériels pour
les policiers le reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch un budget multiplié par
trois une priorité assumer la sécurité
reste un enjeu majeur pour valérie
pécresse la présidente les républicains
de la région ile-de-france est 18
millions d'euros en 2016 pour soutenir
notamment les communes dans leurs
différentes démarches à méré par exemple
dans les yvelines la ville a perçu près
de 100000 euros pour l'installation de
cinq nouvelles caméras s'agit pas que la
région près de la main sur la sécurité
il s'agit que nous aidions toutes les
communes
donc quand un maire souhaite installer
des vidéoprotection rénové de la
vidéoprotection est équipé sa police
municipale est bien la région peut
l'aider financièrement et c'est ce qu'on
a fait cette année en doublant le ce
budget qui était avant à la région
la sécurisation des îles de loisirs
comme celle de saint quentin en yvelines
ou encore des lycées sont également des
priorités de la région depuis la mise en
place du bouclier sécurité en janvier
les transports en commun de leur côté
seront tous dotés de la vidéoprotection
d'ici 2021
la vidéoprotection ça ne marche que si
y'a pas d'angle mort que si tout le
réseau est entièrement couvert sinon
évidemment les actes de délinquance se
produisent là où il n'y a pas de caméra
donc nous avons décidé de faire un plan
100% vidéoprotection dans les trains
avec le renouvellement du matériel
roulant nous y arriverons avant la fin
de la mandature et nous équiperons 70
gares routières dès cette année en lien
avec les ministères de l'intérieur et en
réponse à l'actualité du moment la
région accélère aussi son soutien aux
forces de l'ordre plus de 5 et millions
d'euros sont ainsi consacrés à la
rénovation des commissariats et des
casernes francilienne dans les yvelines
les casernes des quevilly et saint
germain en laye ont reçu des
financements régionaux et nous avons
profité de cet échange avec valérie
pécresse pour recueillir sa réaction
concernant à la fermeture en
ile-de-france de quatre mosquées une
fermeture administrative en raison je
cite d'une idéologie
dicale contraire aux valeurs de la
république est susceptible de constituer
un risque grave d'atteinte à la sécurité
à l'ordre public selon le gouvernement
est la mosquée des cuvées guidon vous
voyez les photos est concerné par cette
mesure une perquisition administrative
s'y étaient déroulés en mai dernier les
services de la préfecture indique elle
que l'un des prêcheurs et tiendrait des
propos virulents appelant à la haine
voire à la violence à l'encontre des
femmes des juifs et des chrétiens et
écoutent et valérie pécresse
je crois que nous devons être absolument
intraitable et intransigeant sur tous
les lieux de culte dans lesquels on
porte atteinte ou on appelle à la
violence qu'on porte atteinte aux
valeurs de la république et je crois que
le ministère de l'intérieur est tout à
fait jaillir dans son rôle à la fois de
surveiller ces lieux de culte et en même
temps de les fermer
lorsqu'il estime que la situation
l'exigé et nous savons effectivement
qu'en ile de france
il y à des lieux dans lesquels on
appelle à porter atteinte aux valeurs de
la république
le grand paris ce projet d'envergure qui
permettra à terme de faire de la
capitale l'une des plus importantes
métropoles mondiales inspirent les
créatifs en tous genres 16-16 progress
est une agence de communication
audiovisuelle basée dans la commune de
plaisir elle rafle toutes les
distinctions avec un film qui présente
les principaux enjeux de ce dossier nous
avons rencontré son fondateur
je rêve d'une ville qui raconte notre
histoire
et qu'ils imaginent d'avenir le grand
paris se dévoile sous la forme d'un film
quatre minutes pour présenter ce projet
qui ont multiplié les distinctions
le film a reçu en octobre trois prix
lors des festivals cannes corporate et
médine corporate de deauville derrière
ce succès david martin et sa société de
production originaire de plaisir on
espère et on espérait vraiment avoir peu
de succès m
un retour très positif sur ce film parce
qu'on s'est vraiment investi
c'est un vrai défi on a tourné avec des
caméras vraiment dernière génération
pour faire des traits des images très
ralenti comme on peut voir le saut la
personne qui saute
depuis la gare du champ de mars au
château de versailles
vingt jours de tournage dans toute
l'ile-de-france ont été nécessaires
commandé par la société du grand paris
le clip a été diffusé en juillet dans
les ambassades françaises derrière cette
première diffusion
ils sont été en fait sensibiliser les
investisseurs internationaux pour les
pousser à participer à investir dans le
grand paris et dans les quartiers de
demain qui nous ont tout de suite fait
confiance en fait pour qu'on leur
propose plutôt un film original qui
sortent des films institutionnels qu'on
peut voir en général et qui privilégie
justement l'humain l'émotion pour pour
commencer à sensibiliser les gens en
fait c'est sprott fête cette année ses
10 ans c'est la première fois qu'un de
ses films est récompensé l'oeuvre
continue de faire le tour des festivals
prochaine étape tokyo verdict le 25
novembre
cette semaine à l'occasion d'halloween
la rédaction vous propose de frissonner
contes légendes et événements
surnaturels nous revenons sur ces
croyances que l'on retrouve aussi dans
le département des yvelines et c'est
avec michael et demi d'euros à présent
que nous allons conclure ce dossier vous
allez nous parler michael de votre
rencontre avec les petits hommes verts
refusent en anglais
bonsoir wilfried les extraterrestres
vivent peut être à des années lumières
du département des yvelines mais ils se
plaisent dans le 78 31 ovnis ont été
répertoriés sur le territoire depuis la
fin des années à 70
wilfrid et 8 n'ont jamais pu être
expliquée selon les ufologues je vois
pas ce que c'est à wilfrid les
spécialistes des objets volants non
identifiés les ivy font donc partie du
top 5 de france des départements les
plus touchés par ce phénomène
je vous vois perplexe wilfrid un petit
peu voilà et pourrait pourtant plusieurs
histoires des sons étranges se sont
produites près de nos studios abus en
cours je vous fais un peu frissonner
vous avez ce genre de boulot à
l'étranger a beaucoup aimé étudier dans
le sud doit effectivement une boule
lumineuse a été observé aux chaînés en
1981 il ya eu un nuage
un nuage de points lumineux à marly le
roi en 1993 il ya une sphère lumineuse
justement à guyancourt le 26
juillet 2012 on écoute pierre ce troc le
président du club d'astronomie à
magnitude 78 il y a beaucoup de
phénomènes qui sont des phénomènes liés
aux satellites artificiels nous voit des
fois dans le ciel et qu'on peut
interpréter comme des choses curieuses
il y a beaucoup d'astéroïdes des toiles
filantes parfois de bonnes idées qui
sont des étoiles filantes très très
brillante ça ça peut vous éclairer
brutalement comme en plein jour
tellement c'est brillant donc il ya
quand même beaucoup de choses dans le
ciel qui peuvent laisser penser à des
choses curieuses
on peut toujours penser ovni oui moi la
plupart des choses que j'ai vu c'était
manifestement des étoiles filantes un
peu de l'aviation on en a beaucoup en
région parisienne ya peut-être qu'une
fois où j'ai vu un truc un peu bizarre
mais faute d'avoir d'explication je dis
plutôt je ne sais pas ce que c'est donc
on imagine colas qu'on aperçoit dans le
ciel ses boules lumineuses ce sont des
feux d'artifice en fait oui quasiment
voilà il ya également eu des crop circle
vous savez où le fric des ronds
circulaire sur le stade de football de
maîtrise de l'anglais vous redire à tous
une doivent donc le 5 février à 2003 il
ya eu en juillet 2011 des requêtes de
feu dans le ciel de châteaufort dans le
club d'astronomie michael 78 certains
astronomes s'opposent les questions la
question comme nous l'expliqué pierre ce
troc
il y avait des gens qui se posent des
questions manifestement qui qui aimerait
bien savoir plus ce qui pose des
questions mais on a beaucoup
d'astronomes amateurs en france sur tout
le territoire qui font des photos toutes
les nuits quand le ciel est dégagé
si on avait vu passer des choses on en
aurait déjà des photos je pense
maintenant les témoignages c'est jamais
très facile des fois on a l'impression
que ça ne bouge pas ou que ça dure très
longtemps alors qu'en fait c'est
l'étonnement qui procure des sensations
et des impressions et qui fait que le
témoignage une fois à na li
et où confronté à d'autres choses
mais plutôt si mais plus n'a plus la
même teneur
alors pourquoi les extraterrestres sont
ils intéressés pour venir dans les
yvelines où il faut et c'est peut-être à
cause des champs voilà il ya énormément
de forêts de champs beaucoup d'espacé on
va dire voilà euros d'ailleurs les
civils sont le département d'île de
france qui compte le plus de zones
rurales ou sinon ils veulent tout
simplement
voilà c'est une vraie info et danse dans
cette chronique oui sinon ils veulent
tout simplement aller visiter je sais
pas le château de versailles par exemple
dans les yvelines à vous de juger
c'est certainement pour suivre vos
émissions sports michael beaucoup
apporté le procès entamé remercient leur
posera peut-être la question on jouait
pas bien sûr et viendront pas tout le
retour sur terre à présent pour la fin
de ce journal nous partons pour le sud
des yvelines où justement vient de voir
le jour la deuxième réserve naturelle
régionale d'île de france le conseil
régional a voté le 13 octobre dernier le
classement dans cette catégorie des
étangs de bonnel découverte de ce site
au coeur du parc de la vallée de
chevreuse avec vous michael justement et
nicolas d'andré les étangs de bonnel
classée réserve naturelle régionale
c'est la décision votée le 13 octobre
dernier par le conseil régional
couronnant plusieurs années de travail
entre la commune et le parc naturel de
la vallée de chevreuse je suis content
parce que c'est une reconnaissance du
travail qui a été fait pendant ces vingt
dernières années
l'espace des erreurs de bonnel et n'est
ce pas ce que nous avions souhaité
classé depuis deux années 90 1990 en
réserve naturelle volontaire et le
statut n'existe en plus il ya une vraie
reconnaissance de la part de la région
poules d'eau canards chevreuil ou
sanglier ce site regorge d'une faune et
d'une flore importante avec notamment 94
espèces d'oiseaux et 36 espèces de
libellules un patrimoine naturel mélangé
à un patrimoine historique
le tout s'étendant sur 22 hectares la
duchesse d'uzès avait fait de cet étang
de cette arme principale de la réserve
naturelle un lieu de balade avec il y
avait un embarcadère pour aller faire de
la barre que vont tous à l'embarcadère
existe toujours mais maintenant c'est
plutôt un observateur poweo le temple
d'amour qui est un magnifique le petit
pont avec débat d une construction
dessus qui est superbe tout ça nous
l'avons réhabiliter jusqu alors nous
étions toujours aidé par le parc naturel
régional donc à la fois par la région et
le département des yvelines et les taux
de subvention va être sensiblement les
mêmes ça ne changera rien si ce n'est
que le comité de scientifiques saura
plus ce régional que départemental
observations relevées et suivis
scientifiques permettront aux experts de
préserver la faune et la flore de cette
nouvelle réserve naturelle
voilà voilà une idée de sortie pour ce
week end merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal revient lundi aux horaires
habituels
[Musique]